oui alors c'est ce que nous sortons
demain dans le public il a entamé un
bras de fer avec la prod avec donc alp
mais aussi tf1 il a contacté plusieurs
avocats dont peut-être maître assous
mais qui ne pourra pas le confirmer
pour en fait démontré que dans un jeu
d'aventuré rechercher de la nourriture
ça fait partie des règles d'accord et
que dans le code d'honneur ce qui est ce
que ce que ce cas lp est ce que denis
brogniart a décrit comme un code
d'honneur écrit rien n'empêche les
candidats d'aller quémander de la
nourriture faut savoir que quand on joue
à quoi claude
faire plier la prod alors un bras de fer
judiciaire risque de s'entamer la prod
dément toute action en justice la preuve
dit qu'elle ne veut absolument pas
attaquer des candidats que les tricheurs
ont essayé ont été assez puni comme ça
mais il faut savoir que claude au-delà
des 100 mille euros qui ne lui sont
passés sous le nez très clairement mardi
il ya aussi il a été désinvité du grand
concours des animateurs par exemple il
avait diffusé sur tf1 en janvier il a
prédit d'auvergnats séparément que
joindre à moi ça c'est un drame mais en
revanche il devait animer un jeu
d'aventuré sur tmc cours en 2022 en
prime et là ça risque aussi de l'or de
lui et moi j'ai un concept pour claude
s'il veut il peut venir sur s'est vite
je l'accueille tout de suite close
sachez le je veux refaire qui peut
battre et je veux faire qui peut battre
l'aude je vous le dis je le prends tout
de suite sur ces 8 dès demain voilà
voilà donc s'il veut je le prends direct
sur ses vitres éclatent ring bien sûr tu
auras catherine et je les adore et vous
verrez que ce sera un énorme carton et
j'y crois à fond à claude encore donc si
tf1 et tmc
voilà pense qu'il n'est plus utile chez
eux il est le bienvenu chez nous comme
disait florent pagny comme on l'avait
révélé il a perdu son contrat
d'exclusivité que tf1 lui avait promis
un don que lui s'estime victime d'un
préjudice est ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que claude et laurent les yeux dans les
yeux continuent à dire on n'a pas triché
on n'a rien fait donc eux ils réclament
effectivement que l'urne soit dépouillé
que l'argent soit versé ils sont furax
contre ça dont qu'ils iront loin mais il
faut quand même répondre à maître assous
que la production grâce aux constats
d'huissiers grâce au travail fait avec
les avocats s'est prémuni d'une
éventuelle attaque judiciaire il pense
qu'on n'aura pas même s'ils sont furax
il ya des actions judiciaires elles y
sont ouvertes et il égalera le constat
d'huissier ou c'est un huissier vous lui
demandez de constater un téléphone il
dit au téléphone bernard montiel des
huissiers mais ce qui est très important
de rappeler c'est une règle qui va
beaucoup amuser vos téléspectateurs et
même je pense l'ensemble des personnes
ici présentes c'est qu'on vous présente
koh lanta comme un jeu or c'est pas un
jeu c'est un divertissement mesmin
juridiquement un jeu notamment un jeu
d'argent c'est quand vous avez une
chance de gain en l'espèce cent mille
euros mais un risque de perte le jeu
qu'on connaît tous et l'auto est
pourquoi on joue pas au loto toute la
journée parce que à chaque fois faut
miser donc en l'espèce est ce qu'il ya
un risque de perte d'argent pour
n'importe quel des participants ce type
de programme jamais et si jamais ils le
demandaient ne serait ce que 1 euro pour
jouer ça serait impossible pour les
producteurs parce que du coup il serait
organisateurs de jeux d'argent or on ne
peut pas être organisateurs de jeux
d'argent et producteurs c'est la raison
pour laquelle le plus grand producteur
de télé réalité qui est aussi tout en
haut de votre pyramide un cyril hanouna
a également investi dans lé pari en
ligne lamy dans d'autres sociétés et ne
mélange pas donc c'est que lui-même fait
bien le distinguo d'ailleurs votre beat
clic et collante ces techniques alors
est ce qu'il peut récupérer les sons
binauraux qu il va récupérer beaucoup
plus bas mais parce que comme
l'expliquait très justement à elle voilà
c'est que non seulement il va gagner les
100 mille euros parce qu'ils leur
viennent et on sait que c'est lui qui a
gagné mais tout le préjudice qu'il a
subi à pour seul et unique responsable
la production et cette espèce de mise en
scène assez grotesque de dire je ne
dépouille pas mais je vous le donne pas
les noms mais je vous fait comprendre
que c'est bel et bien lui qui aurait
triché c'est encore une fois notion qui
n'a aucune valeur en droit du travail et
ils ont aggravé son préjudice de manière
extrêmement c'est pas la problématique
c'est vous savez que c'est la production
qui décide ce qu'on diffusait ce qu'on
diffuse pas et donc s'est mis en scène
cette espèce de 2,2
d'exclusion temps du jeu que social
assaisonner public était dégoûté en fait
c'est ça mais les fans de koh lanta non
mais les fans
2010 ont ils sont sûrement très charmant
mais un peu naïf de croire que tout se
passe comme ce qui était les différents
oui c'est moi et moi je suis comme eux
mais je
m assure moi je suis comme moi je pense
aussi que tout est vrai tout ça
franchement sinon sinon qu'on imagine
laterrière et ses traces mais il n'y a
pas de trucage sa lampe et ses montées
vous avez des millions d'heures et
monsieur castaldi pourra le confirmer
vous prenez un programme de télé réalité
vu le nombre de caméras et le nombre
d'heures film et vous ne diffusez même
pas 0,0 à 0,1 pour cent vous avez des
centaines de milliers d'heures pour
quelques heures de télédiffusion donc
vous avez un montage et on peut dans ces
conditions de faire mon rayon fait un
personnage au mettre en valeur d'autres
ou au contraire mettre en valeur des
caractères qui pourrait pousser le
public à apprécier ou au contraire moins
apprécié certains partisans c'est un
programme audiovisuel d'ailleurs ils les
ont toujours présenté comme un progrès
sur l'audiovisuel qui relèvent non pas
du documentaire et de la fiction maël
est ce que vous avez vu la photo qui
pourra officiellement incriminé beaucoup
les autres aventuriers d'avoir mon jeu
on a énormément un vrai pour essayer de
se la procurer on a appelé tous les
polynésiens qu'on pouvait trouver sur
place quand j'ai parlé à quelqu'un qui a
vu la photo dont kim expliqué que
c'était un selphy avec 4 des aventuriers
qui participé au dîner clandestins c'est
donc en selle fille pris comme ça qu'il
y aurait laurent sur la photo il les
trois autres on n'a pas les noms mais
nous en tout cas quand on a essayé de se
la procurer
on a eu le sentiment que la prod avait
mis le la main sur cette photo et avait
versé assez d'argent pour la rendre très
confidentiel